when making roasted pork at home it's
really important to have enough time
because you want enough time for it to
marinate and you want plenty of time for
its roast
hi I'm Daniel and I'm the owner of elk
cochinita today I'm gonna show you how
to make the Cuban sandwich I will coach
an ethos a small 4dc restaurant and
silver like we're neighborhood
restaurant so everything real simple
authentic traditional Cuban food just
like my grandmother made it our
restaurant is turning 30 years this year
started with my grandmother and
ultimately my great-grandfather in Cuba
who also had a restaurant we were
nominated to compete in the Cuban
sandwich festival in Tampa I think we
won because I got to make them with my
friends and family and their help and
love kind of really made us stand out so
the recipe were used is really straight
from my grandma the marinade remake it's
lime juice garlic cumin oregano and salt
and pepper my grandmother always used
lime juice but I think that was just an
evolution of being in LA and having
different products available to her so
we use pork butts bone-in for our
latrone it takes a lot of time and love
so when we start our pork we bring it in
we slice it across the grain a few times
on the top and a few times on the bottom
and that helped make it a little more
tender and a little easier to eat so
once it's out of the oven it's it's
really ready to go
so at the restaurant we're making pork
all day long we go through thousands of
pounds of pork a week when the pork
comes in we process it and marinate it
or at least like eight to ten hours and
then either every single night and day
or every night we're roasting pork butts
real slow and low 250 degrees for about
eight to 10 hours we roast it in big
pans with lid on it kind of generate a
little bit of steam inside the pan so
overnight it's slowly rendering fat and
also steaming in its juices once it's
ready it has the perfect amount of sauce
you need for it I always wanted to cook
ever since I was real little I used to
spend the summers with my grandmother
kind of that kid on the milk crate
stirring the pot really just loved
everything about the restaurant business
so when we make a Cuban sandwich we
first open it so that we can put it in
the oven
this way we get everything hot and
toasty our cheese is melting our pork is
hot and then red
before we put it on the press we add the
pickles this way they stay crunchy still
and give it that texture and balance
that we really look for if we were
making a Cuban sandwich at home I
typically would just use a cast-iron pan
maybe a second cast-iron pan or a brick
covered in foil you really just want a
little bit of pressure even low heat to
get it nice and toasty and have the
cheese melt our restaurant customers are
are certainly from the neighborhood and
I think that's always been the identity
of the restaurant it's a neighborhood
restaurant our food hasn't changed but
the neighborhood has so I think our
customers are really just a reflection
of the neighborhood you know I would
love to grow and expand the restaurant
but my dream is to really preserve my
grandmother's cuisine and her culture
and kind of to keep that Cuban culture
going oh yes
[Music]